[Applause]
head man the basketball right there you
look at kawhi leonard nice little
hesitation
there you see the line he has not
disappointed in his clipper debut here
is kawaii
swiveling to the cup oh a sledgehammer
follows
they let him operate in this area where
he's very good
nice spin-off spin i cut out the spin
cycle
and this dude is this dude is so good
siakim leaves it in with the right hand
[Applause]
what a pass by leonard and another
finish inside
and telegraph that pass beverly in the
corner
allow yourself to even be open when you
come off of it
leonard an aggressive drive oh my
look out below
the screen right there two dribbles and
dunks on two people
wow what a play that was the driver they
brought to you
big possession right here for the
clippers
hawaii has 34. an aggressive drive oh
hello nasty
kawhi knows if he comes off a screen
they're double teaming
so turn down the screen and go dunk on
whoever's in the paint
that was a big time play by a big time
player brian
i'll tell you what we see that every
once in a while from kawhi those strong
drives we've seen it a few times tonight
someone might need to give colin sexton
the hugs tell him
it's not your fault leonard trying to do
the same thing
fly baby fly but right here
the quick jab brandon knight from the
initial possession
lost his footing and kawhi leonard
calibrated that move
curry gets around
anthony smith has his three blocked by
kawhi
what a blocked shot right there and then
back the other way
look out below oh my goodness
steph curry for one and then blocks a
shot and then gets out
and one dunks the basketball on
luca doncic i mean what a
couple plays right there by kawhi
leonard i mean nice finish right there
lou williams back out there for doc
rivers here's leonard in attack mode
and the clippers lead 16-4 and kawhi
gets that but how about this dunk right
here
it must be nice to be able to move that
basketball from one hand to the other
hand
you're talking about the nba finals
teams of the golden state warriors
here's muttered oh
puts it down watch the palm
we all know about his hands and then the
finish
we've been seeing him dunk on cats with
his left hand
lately he goes back to his dominant hand
the right hand
and makes a poster with a couple guys
who wants to get in there
[Applause]
both teams struggling to shoot early
just two for nine combined leonard
the high percentage shot and he thought
there was contact
afterwards jokic
good stunt there by marcus morris shot
clock at nine
murray takes it and tried to jam and was
rejected at the rim it was
almost saved by beverly kawhi leonard is
doing it all
what a defensive play well jamal murray
was trying to
catch a body here look at this oh my
goodness
it looks like he blocked it with one of
those fingers of
what a beautiful block here it's like
he's got a baseball glove on
he blocked it with his middle finger
that is amazing
the defensive player that pat beverly is
jamal murray goes to work oh what a
great spin move
and a jackhammer inside by leonard
you're right i'm going to ask in a
second who before all this began was
your pit
he'll crow pour that in pretty play by
leonard
as he took it off that baseline final
teams
look at this as he just put it back up
and through
with a lot of congestion around wallet
kawhi leonard has a game-high 24.
he goes from the wing to the lane oh my
hello
nasty kawhi leonard with 26.
creating off the dribble it's not fast
it's not
quick but it's very effective able to
get to the rim
the clips are thrown away trying to cut
it is indiana in the midwest
it's slightly midwest you're getting out
you're in the eastern time zone says
enough of this
chatter ended right now young man
see kawhi down the lane indy if you went
if you were going to indiana pass
indiana you were considered really west
leonard crosses over roby cruel and
punches for the iron
and flushes it in with the right hand
timeout oklahoma city
[Music]
it's a service that i provide all
clippers you may have to private
oh my hello nasty
kawhi leonard now with 18 and the
clippers lead by
10. to get excited when he puts the ball
on the floor and he throws the ball
and the defensive body down with it
he's something special shows you the
strength this young man has vanassa said
more time on that mark he was a little
anxious
great spin move and kawhi explodes
and gives the clippers the lead why
leonard just
navigating look at brynn is trying to
tag him to allow
chris to recover but listen if he gets
those shoulders past you dante comes
over
good business decision to step out of
the way there dante
[Applause]
look at kawhi there are 30 that didn't
go through
hayward for three misses badly in george
with a leaping rebound
lob to leonard oh my
you'll see the hand go up in the air and
elevating getting those two arms up
finishing nobody picks up hayward's man
in transition as well kawhi playing by
himself
concern you have in moments like this is
a team now
is playing with a ton of confidence as
kawhi
leonard put that one in the highlight
reel
[Applause]
why bringing it up that long stride
just like reggie jackson they are
leading
a phoenix team in the second of a back
to back a huge two game oh my goodness
look how quick this dunk is i mean
the extension right over ayton
i mean this is your seven footer
oh that's beautiful after finishing with
the fifth best record in the nba and a
ton of injuries during the regular
season
leonard gets the steal three on one
[Applause]
slams it down
hanging in his room man
look he got those paws and all i'm gonna
say is this
when kawhi gets going and just
put him in the basket in the backdrop
but it's starting with luca again taking
the pick and roll double team
the clip is the lineup that they have on
the floor they have the ability my
goodness
kawhi leonard with a 7-3 man right there
[Applause]
that's a big-time finish by kwai lennon
[Applause]
that's two dungs tonight tip duncan that
one
leva way out on leonard george sets the
screen
now finney smith picks him up shot clock
at seven leonard drives down and the
flush
with authority what you see earlier was
turning the corner and getting to the
paint now he's settling offensively
here's leonard on the drive and the
finish kawhi
leonard throws it down and the clippers
back up by two
now with a five-point lead mark and choi
let it
putting his head down and attacking the
paint donovich had really improved as a
defender
throughout his career as he turns that
over kauai with those
large hands with the slam at the other
end
kawhi leonard the catalyst defensively
and offensively for the los
angeles clippers and he has led this
team
no rush here for la leonard seven of
shoot kawhi makes his move oh
wow a major kawhi light
incredible on both ends of the ball
and why leonard emphatic
with that finish the nba playoffs on tnt
western conference semis presented by
fan dual sportsbook